زلازل متواصله فيضانات وابنيه تتساقط
مستنجدون يطلبون يد العون اما من الغرق
واما من تحت الركام او مصابون وجدوا
انفسهم بلا معين هكذا بدت الصوره من جزيره
لامبو الاندونيسيه في منتصف اغسطس من
العام 2018
فماذا حدث
في التاسع والعشرين من يوليو وفيما كانت
الساعه تقترب من السابعه صباحا على ظهر
جزيره الواقعه ضمن الارخبيل الاندونيسي
على المحيط الهادئ اذ بزلزال عنيف ضرب
الجزيره لنحو ثلاثين ثانيه شوهدت المباني
تتحرك واهتزت بوابات المنتجعات السياحيه
سقطت اسقف المنازل وتكسرت النوافذ
والابواب كما فاض المحيط وغطاء اجزاء
كبيره من اليابسه وداهم السياح في حمامات
السباحه متسببا في مقتل 14 شخصا على الاقل
واصابه العشرات
بعد نحو اربع ساعات من الهزات الارضيه بدا
ان الجزيره قد هدات لكن جوف الارض لم يهدا
بعد فصدع الذي اصاب جزءها الشمالي استمر
بالانقسام ليحدث زلزال اخر بلغت اثاره
المناطق الشرقيه والشماليه وذلك بعد اسبوع
بالضبط من الزلزال الاول عند قرابه الساعه
السابعه مساء لكن قوته هذه المره بلغت سبع
درجات مع استمرار الهزات الارتداديه حدثت
الانهيارات الارضيه في كل مكان تقريبا
فتهدمت مئات المنازل وهرع السكان الى
الطرقات في مشهد مريب منهم من وجد ملجا
ومنهم من افترش الطريق فيما حزم السياح
امتعتهم متجهين لمطارات المغادره كانت
المياه الفائده من المحيط على وشك ان
تتسبب في تسونامي بالمنطقه التي باتت في
غضون ايام قليله بؤره منكوبه استمر في
التشقق واحدث زلزالين اخرين في التاسع
والتاسع عشر من اغسطس كما سجلت اكثر من
الف هزه ارتداديه في غضون 20 يوما ليترك
الكثير من الاهالي في حاله ياس مما
ينتظرهم واستنقطاع الخدمات ونقص
الاحتياجات الاساسيه كان شمال الجزيره
ومدينه مترام مركز زلزال الاكثر تضررا
فاكثر من نصف المنازل تدمرت او لم تعد
صالحه للسكن كما ضربت الزلازل البنيه
التحتيه وسبل العيش تم الابلاغ عن وفاه
5003 شخصا على الاقل فيما اصيب اكثر من
سبعه الاف واجبر اربع مئه وواحد وثلاثون
واربع مئه وسته وثلاثون على مغادره
منازلهم بعد تضرر ما يقرب من 75 الف منزل
رغم ان الزلازل بهذا الحجم ليست غريبه في
قوس جزيره المحيط الهادئ حيث انها احدى
اكثر المناطق نشاطا زلزاليا على وجه الارض
لكن هذا الشق الكبير الذي اصاب الجزيره
ترك خلفه الكثير من التكهنات حول شكل
الحياه في هذه الجزيره السياحيه مستقبلا
[موسيقى]